you feel like such a good mom right now
[Music]
hi with your family
hey we're the Montoya's the exact line
boss today yes
I'm gonna get to boss around my parents
we're ready for anything I mean if you
think back to when we met each other we
were pretty fun people I'm a little
excited but also on tilts because I
don't know what what's in store for us
today I'm gonna have a lot of sweet
words yes get apples okay follow the
boss I'll make them play water booth
that would be paradise ladies go first
oh it's like a desert Pizza six nice saw
body
I think that's the last thing goals and
sprinkles and jellybeans oh boy how
lovely it jumps Nicholas is very
creative and he came up with some great
ideas
[Music]
I have too much already do I have - yeah
leave - line the boss that's your day
you get to do what you want no matter
how you stomach feels later water
balloon
[Music]
I think making a mess is actually an
important part of childhood they
probably have least out on that it was
actually pretty fun it was nice to just
let go and not be so responsible and up
tired a lot of fun things they didn't we
are you awake like oh they come up with
a kid bus - yeah